S
TONIGHT.
I'LL SEE YOU TOMORROW.
AC 360 STARTS NOW.
>>> GOOD EVENING, PRESIDENT
BIDEN IS DUE TO ARRIVE IN ROME
ANY MINUTE.
AT LEAST NOT YET.
HOUSE DEMOCRATIC LEADERS PUSHING
BACK A VOTE ON AN ALREADY SENATE
BILL.
PROGRESSIVES REFUSING TO SUPPORT
IT UNTIL SENATE MODERATES SIGN
OFFER ON THE BUILD BACK BELTER
SOCIAL ENVIRONMENTAL
LEGISLATION.
ONE OF THOSE MODERATES JOE MAN
G
MANCHIN SAID IT'S THE PRODUCT OF
NEGOTIATIONS.
I WOULD HOPE ALL OF US CONTINUE
TO DEAL IN GOOD FAITH AND DO
WHAT IS RIGHT FOR THE FUTURE OF
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
NOT A SIGN OFF BUT NOT A KISS
OFF.
JUST A FEW MINUTES AGO, I SPOKE
ABOUT THE STATE OF PLAY WITH
WHITE HOUSE DOMESTIC ADVISER AND
FORMER U.N. AMBASSADOR, SUSAN
RICE.
>> YOU WERE WITH THE PRESIDENT
ON CAPITOL HILL.
CONGRESSWOMAN SAYING THE HOUSE
PROGRESSIVE CAUCUS WON'T HAVE
THE STRUCTURE BILL WITHOUT THE
BUILD BACK BETTER ACT.
I KNOW YOU TALKED TO MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS ALL DAY.
WHERE ARE WE RIGHT NOW ON SOME
OF THE KEY STAKE HOLDERS?
>> I WAS UP WITH THE THE
PRESIDENT AND THE HOUSE MEMBERS
OF THE DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS.
WHAT WAS NOTABLE IS HOW BROAD
THE SUPPORT HAS BEEN FOR THE
FRAME WORK THAT THE PRESIDENT
LAID OUT TODAY.
THE MOST PROGRESSIVE WING OF OUR
PARTY, INCLUDING CONGRESSWOMAN
AND THE PROGRESSIVE CAUCUS AS
YOU HEARD THEM SAY TO THE
MODERATE WING OF OUR PARTY.
EVERYBODY UNDERSTANDS THAT WHAT
IS IN THE BUILD BACK BETTER
FRAME WORK IS GOOD FOR THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
P CHILD CARE MADE AFRTABLE FOR
FAMILIES THAT ARE STRUGGLING
PAYING OVER A QUARTER OF THEIR
INCOME FOR CHILD CARE.
CAN'T AFFORD IT.
UNIVERSAL PRECARE.
HOME CARE MADE AVAILABLE AND
ACCESSIBLE FOR OUR PARENTS AND
LOVED ONES AND THOSE WHO ARE
DISABLED WHO CAN'T OTHERWISE GET
CARE.
EXTRAORDINARY INVEST MS IN OUR
ENVIRONMENT SO THAT OUR PLANET
CAN FIGHT AND SUSTAIN AGAINST
CLIMATE CHANGE.
THESE ARE EXTRAORDINARY ELEMENTS
OF THIS PACKAGE.
HOUSING, INVESTMENTS IN EQUITY.
>> THE SUPPORT IS CLEARLY NOT SO
WIDESPREAD BECAUSE JOE MANCHIN
DOESN'T LIKE A LOT OF THE
ENVIRONMENTAL THINGS.
SORRY TO INTERRUPT BUT CHUCK
SCHUMER HAS NOT SAID IF MANCLIN
AND SINEMA WILL VOTE ON THAT.
>> WE HAVE OUR KNOWLEDGE FROM
SPENDING HOURS AND HOURS OVER
WEEKS AND MONTHS WITH THEM AND
MANY OTHERS IN THE DEMOCRATIC
CAUCUS.
WE HAVE FRAME WORK THAT WE ARE
CONFIDENT CAN PASS THE SENATE AS
WELL AS THE HOUSE.
WE'VE NOT SAID THAT BEFORE
TODAY.
WE ARE CONFIDENT THAT WE HAVE A
FRAME WORK THAT CAN PASS BOTH
HOUSES AND THAT IS A CONFIDENCE
BORN OF EXTENSIVE, EXTENSIVE
ENGA
ENGAGEMENTS WITH THOSE WHOSE
VOTES WE NEED.
>> DOES THE WHITE HOUSE HAVE A
FIRM COMMITMENT FROM THE
PROGRESSIVE CAUCUS?
>> WHAT I'LL SAY TO YOU WHETHER
SPEAKING ABOUT THE PROGRESSIVE
CAUCUS, I'M NOT GOING SPEAK FOR
MY MEMBER OF CONGRESS.
I'LL SPEAK ON BEHALF OF THE
WHITE HOUSE AND THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES AND MY OWN
BEHALF.
IT'S NOT HELPFUL OR APPROPRIATE
FOR ME TO CHARACTERIZE ANYBODY
ELSE.
>> FAIR ENOUGH.
>> I KNOW THERE'S BROAD SUPPORT
FOR THE BIPARTISAN
INFRASTRUCTURE FRAME WORK AND
THE BUILD BACK BETTER PACKAGE.
NOBODY IS SAYING THEY WON'T VOTE
FOR IT BECAUSE OF THE SUBSTANCE.
THEY ARE SAYING THEY ARE VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF THE SUBSTANCE OF
THE FRAME WORK FROM ALL
SPECTRUMS OF OUR PARTY.
THAT'S THE IMPORTANT THING.
THE PROCEDURAL STUFF IS, WANT TO
MINIMIZE IT BUT IT WILL BE
WORKED OUT.
THIS THE SAUSAGE MAKING THAT IS
WASHINGTON POLITICS AND I'M VERY
CONFIDENT THAT AT THE END OF THE
DAY, WE WILL HAVE A BIPARTISAN
INFRASTRUCTURE FRAME WORK AND A
BUILD BACK BETTER FRAME WORK
WHICH ARE GOING TO BE
EXTRAORDINARILY BENEFICIAL FOR
OUR PLANET, AMERICAN FAMILIES,
FOR JOBS AND FOR OUR PEOPLE IN
GENERAL.
>> I NEVER EXPECTED TO BE IN
THIS SAUSAGE BUSINESS BUT I FIND
MYSELF IN THE SAUSAGE BUSINESS.
I DO HAVE TO ASK, IS THE WHITE
HOUSE IN SUPPORT OF BOTH OF
THESE BILLS BEING VOTED ON BACK
TO BACK?
I KNOW THAT'S SAUSAGE MAKING BUT
IT SEEMS TO BE HOLDING THINGS
UP.
>> WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF BOTH OF
THESE BILL.
THE PRESIDENT COULD NOT HAVE
BEEN CLEARER.
WE WANTS THEM VOTED AND VOTED AS
SOON AS POSSIBLE.
THAT'S THE BOTTOM LINE.
WE WILL LIVE IT TO FIGURE OUT
THE APPROPRIATE SEQUENCES.
WE WANT THEM DONE AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE.
THEY ARE VITAL TO OUR ECONOMY,
THE WELL BEING OF OUR PEOPLE AND
GLOBAL COMPETITIVENESS.
>> CAN YOU SAY IF THE PAID LEAVE
IS NO LONGER IN THIS.
IT HAD BEEN 12 WEEKS.
IT WAS DOWN TO FOUR WEEKS.
I KNOW IT WAS VERY IMPORTANT TO
YOU, TO THE PRESIDENT.
HE TALKED ABOUT IT AT THE TOWN
HALL LAST WEEK.
IS THAT OUT?
>> ANDERSON, I THINK VERY SADLY
THERE WERE NOT THE VOTES IN THE
SENATE TO INCLUDE PAID LEAVE.
THE PRESIDENT BELIEVES DEEPLY IN
THE VITAL IMPORTANCE OF PAID
LEAVE FOR MOTHER, FATHERS,
AMERICAN FAMILIES.
HE'S GOING TO CONTINUE TO FIGHT
FOR IT AS WELL AS OTHER
PROVISIONS THAT DID NOT MAKE IT
INTO THIS FRAME WORK AGREEMENT.
THIS IS NOT THE LAST YEAR OF THE
BIDEN PRESIDENCY.
IT'S THE FIRST YEAR OF THE
PRESIDENCY.
ALREADY WE'VE HAD EXTRAORDINARY
SUCCESS WITH THE AMERICAN RESCUE
PLAN AND WE WILL CONTINUE TO
HAVE SUCCESS AS THESE TWO
IMPORTANT PIECES OF LEGISLATION
PASS.
THAT DUPTS MEAN WE'RE DONE.
>> YOU KNOW FROM YOUR WORK, DO
YOU WORRY THE LACK OF A DEAL
RIGHT NOW UNDERMINES THE
PRESIDENT'S MESSAGE ON THE
GLOBAL STAGE ESPECIALLY THEIR
COUNTRY'S RUSSIA AND CHINA WHO
ARE PERPETUATING THE IDEA THAT
DEMOCRACY IS DYSFUNCTIONAL.
>> THEY ARE NOT EVEN SHOWING UP
AT THE G20.
I KNOW WHAT THAT SAYS ABOUT
THEM.
WE WILL BE THERE.
AMERICA WILL LEAD UNDER
PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN AND WE WILL
ENSURE THAT OUR INTEREST AND
THOSE OF OUR PARTNER AND ALLIES
ARE ADVANCED IN THE CONTEXT OF